that growing as a communicator forget
YouTube it's just one of the most
important and Powerful skills that you
could ever grow in if you grow as a
communicator your income will grow your
relationships will be stronger you'll be
able to enlist more people in your
vision you'll be able to communicate
your ideas more powerfully you will
ultimately make a greater impact in the
world why would I hesitate to invest in
something that powerful if there's
anything I'm going to study and improve
my game in I definitely want to do that
in
communication
communication is not only one of the
most high-powered skills in en but
especially if you're going to be a
content creator that's the essence of
what it is and of course communication
can be verbal it could be your Cadence
when speaking but communication is
everything down from the crafting of the
video itself as it weaves into all the
little Parts but in relation to
essentially public speaking and on
camera speaking the first thing was a
decision the second thing was uh getting
resourced I remember back might have
been 2008 or n where I got on eBay and I
BR bought a 12 CD set on how to be a
better communicator and so yes CDs not
mp3s and it was John Maxwell and Chris
Weidner four of the discs were on just a
bunch of vocabulary words and and
they're actually teaching on teaching I
think what was also helpful is you know
one of sometimes the missing pieces I
believe that the e-learning industry is
one of the biggest opportunities right
now people packaging what they know in
an online course it's going to be a
billion dollar in indust a day industry
soon and however a lot of people are
kind of just going you know
half-heartedly or or they're jumping
into it do you know how to teach do you
know how to structure your content have
you ever study teaching itself or adult
Adult Learning Theory so I've had the
privilege of I was a part of a small
Bible College and then I taught in that
same school so these early years forced
me and then I was also in school I was
learning how to prepare a sermon
preparing A good sermon is actually like
preparing a good YouTube video you you
want to have a hook you want to get the
listener engaged you are you have a
premise you have a a a point you want to
make and then you're building around
that point there's structure to it and
then going deeper if you're actually
taking someone through a curriculum so
all of that served me and it was not
passive I it's kind of like Malcolm
Gladwell popularizes the 10,000 hour
rule think it's 10,000 hours doing the
thing or 10,000 hours of practice which
is an incomplete truth and not what he
discovered what he discovered was one
distinct word it's not 10,000 hours of
practice it's 10,000 hours of deliberate
practice and that changes everything
being deliberate is the fact that you're
there taking notes observing the details
one of the things that breaks my heart
the most is I don't see people take
notes anymore
um I'm a big Faith guy Church guy I
don't see people who take notes in
church I think it's their loss however
I'll go to all kinds of conferences you
know social media conferences marketing
conferences I'm shocked people aren't
taking notes and I'm like man you you
you bought a ticket you hope to learn
what you're absorbing and you also I
hope you you want the end result you
want to learn what the session is
teaching retain it apply it so that your
business grows so that ultimately the
money hits your bank account for you and
your and so you can make a bigger
difference in the world what else you
going to do right now why why why are
you a why are you scrolling on Instagram
but B even if you're paying attention
why aren't you not taking notes all the
data would reveal that even if you never
refer to it again it's going to be more
sticky by writing it down you're going
to retain it better but if you review it
once your retention goes up like 4X and
so I not only will take notes through
basically everything I take notes all
the time um it's kind of a rabbit Trail
but I think there's value here like I
take I took notes on our team's inogram
presentations once because I want to uh
our whole team at our all team went
through inogram personality tests and I
was like I want to know them better and
so I'm going to take notes this entire
time as opposed to uh just you know
passively listening or getting
distracted and so the punchline is uh
Not only was I always in a deliberate
practice mindset but no matter what
session I was sitting in it might not
even have been the content I was
interested in I would take notes on the
delivery I would have those two parts of
the observation
what can we learn here from the person
that's speaking what can I learn at this
conference what can I learn from
studying great communicators on TED
Talks how can I reverse engineer there's
a good book called decoding greatness
man it's one of my favorite books you'd
love it if you haven't heard about it by
Ron Friedman and it's it's actually
about the skill of reverse
engineering and saying that all the
greats look at the Masters and model the
Masters and break down the pieces and
reverse engineer talks about how Gates
and how Steve Jobs was so mad at Bill
Gates because he's like you stole our
software and uh you know I can't believe
and he goes Steve actually um we both
stole it from Xerox like they have had
this you know and so to that end it was
it was somebody else inspired them and
so communication best practices are it's
an lifelong journey lifelong learning
and and so being intentional and getting
around great communicators and then
deliberately learning and then asking
questions when I had the opportunity to
get feedback on my sessions um when I
speak on stage hey what could I have
done better if I could get coach from
somebody if you can enroll in somebody's
program to be become a better speaker
I've done all of the above and then I
think the final thing that's also a
missing piece for many I heard one
person say and I I don't know if I
respect this but but I I I maybe they're
busy whatever they go you know what I
post stuff online and I never watch it
back and I'm like why are we bragging I
heard somebody else say I don't take
notes anymore I just I I'm they've
really arrived at some kind of success
I'm like why are we bragging I take
notes on sessions I already know if I
actually know it I'm still writing it
down because repetition is the father of
learning and the mother of Mastery I'm
trying to absorb this repetition is the
key to training I want to repeat
something so much not just so that I
remember but so that I never forget I
want it like in my spirit so that I can
be world class the final thing though is
is watching game tap tape and you know
Kobe May rest in power was famous for
watching his gam tape back whether he
won or lost because he wanted to learn
and be a a master of what he was doing
so it's watching back your YouTube
videos or a web class you do or anything
that you've done I just noticed on a
recent podcast that I every few words I
said and so on and so forth and so on
and so forth and I'm telling you about
that now because I watched this this
morning and I was like I need to have a
a
a better go-to phrase or more variety in
my reset phrase I I want to be
thoughtful about not saying and so on
and so forth 38 times in one podcast
mind you I just got out of auna with
Andrew Andre J weirdest podcast I've
ever been where I was with him and his
co-host in a sauna at five levels of
heat so I might not have been in the
greatest state of mine nevertheless I'm
like I you know I'm still a good podcast
not overly critical or I don't go I
don't C asiz and spin out I just go okay
that's a good distinction I I should I
want to work on that by reviewing my
game tape so I hope those are helpful
taking notes deliberate practice
reviewing your game tape and then having
kind of a grace-based productivity and a
grace-based growth process that you're
not comparing yourself to anyone of
course when you start communicating you
might be saying a lot of ums you might
not be super sharp you might not be
super polished it's a big Journey it's
been deliberate practice over decades
now for me of being intentional with
this so just pacing yourself having
Grace on the journey but making a
decision that growing as a communicator
forget YouTube it's just one of the most
important and Powerful skills that you
could ever grow in if you grow as a
communicator your income will grow your
relationships will be stronger you'll be
able to enlist more people in your
vision you'll be able to communicate
your ideas more powerfully you will
ultimately make a greater impact in the
world it goes back to one of those
things that it's like why would I
hesitate to invest in something that
powerful if there's anything I'm going
to study and improve my game in I
definitely want to do that in
communication I want to ask you this
question because I get this question
asked a lot they'll say Chris you're a
great communicator great public speaker
I like how you speak about things your
tone your Cadence and all that and the
question they ask is is a strange
question but I get the spirit of it
which is how do I become you now I'm GNA
ask you this question more specifically
you just gave us a bunch of notes but I
want to ask you kind of maybe a side
question here which is who do you model
yourself after that's a little bit off
and weird that people didn't know I I'll
answer that question as well because how
do you learn to speak and to present and
get your flow from is there a person
living dead somebody you're watching
listening to that you're like here's a
person and I picked this up from them
and I'm trying to do that myself I'll
try to go fast I mean there's so many
and in fact in the back of YouTube
Secrets uh the acknowledgments is a very
meaningful portion and it was updated
for the second edition um one of
the biggest privileges I've had was also
being a video editor
and one of the things I learned about
Joel ostein and who's probably the most
maybe the influ most influential
Communicator broadcasted most widely
globally uh in terms of television and
radio he was a video editor for his
dad and his dad was the pastor of the
church before him and they started a TV
show so Joel would edit his dad's
messages well most preachers they talk
long 45 minutes 52 minutes an hour and 3
minutes well he had to edit his dad's
sermons into 27 minutes for TV so week
after week he was sitting down listening
to good communication but learning how
to be precise learning how learning
distinctions and finding ways to maybe
say more things in less time there's
another good book out right now called
smart brevity that I'm reading about I
think an important skill set for today's
world
and he as a result took his
communication to another level so being
a video editor myself and having
freelance clients one of the people I
learned in particular humor timing from
was a guy named Dr Dave Martin so I was
doing freelance social media and video
editing for him for a couple years I I
learned a lot of things I learned that
he also he had mainly one message or two
messages that he would share everywhere
because he would speak new places which
popped the myth that I always had to be
saying new things that it actually spoke
to that if I could craft core messages
and actually say a few things really
well that that's more poignant than
trying to always come up with something
new nobody could can can effectively do
that it's very difficult to always have
like a polished and so I learned that I
he he would include a lot of jokes in
his material so I would list literally
second for second because I'm editing
video so I would learn timing Cadence
that is one um genre that is very worth
studying see and many people already
would probably watch Netflix specials of
comedian
comedians are are the greatest
communicators on the planet they test
jokes in different environments they get
the good ones they learn the timing of
them you'll notice their vocal delivery
vocal change the tone Whispering
speaking it louder and then even
mannerisms that reinforce what it is
that they're doing if you start watching
hope maybe after listening to this
podcast everyone's future is ruined
because they can it's like people who
learn storytelling and can never watch a
movie again because they understand and
like three act sequence and they're like
ah I know it's going to happen because
the antagonist and the pro you maybe not
be won't be able to watch a comedian
without deliver practice now okay I'm
watching Kevin Hart I'm watching Dave
Chappelle through a new lens of how and
when and pausing leaving some margin in
how they speak and so uh Dr Dave
Martin's one John braier would be
another one in the church world and and
people maybe have different background
if they've been a part of any church
where they'd say I did not get exposed
to like a worldclass communicators in
church in my experience I think maybe
because of the uh types of churches I
was exposed to
communication Beyond even just preaching
or teaching was elevated to an extremely
high level where I've had the
opportunity to sit in rooms with some of
the world's probably greatest
communicators especially in the church
world and whether that's a TD Jake or a
Joel hin or working for Benny Perez in
Las Vegas again an incredible
communicator and certain jokes or timing
or even mannerisms certainly have
influenced me and then watching a lot of
Gary ve there could be things that have
come through or watching Casey neistat
where there' probably be nothing visual
or that I'd say but just as you study
storytelling or as you study editing or
also as you practice a lot so there's a
ton of influences um in my communication
and those are a few I promised I would
share some of my own and it was kind of
interesting how much of our life is
different but overlap at the same time I
have to give my hats off my hat off to
to Joel because I watched him speak my
my wife's a born again Christian she was
watching for a period of time so I kind
of was able to peek over her shoulder
and look this this gentleman is very
good at storytelling pulling you in
making complex Concepts very simple to
understand and repeatable and he's very
charismatic in his way he's a powerful
speaker but he also doesn't put himself
on a pedestal he brings himself down by
referring to a dad he always says and he
speaks like that like you're a grown man
with children yourself but he refers to
his dad this way and so it makes you
feel like I can relate I can get on this
train and ride this with him um the
other person that the the types of
people you mentioned are comedians I
watch comedians for for different
reasons mostly for stage presence and
storytelling and so I remember this one
where Kevin Hart goes out into a
football siiz stadium maybe all of his
concerts are like that but he walks on
with a Swagger I've never seen before
and he's a small man and he knows his
his physical comedy and how he does
things right he's swinging his arms
around and I think I need to steal that
and so I'm watching it rewinding it and
I'm practicing the exact same walk we
talk about modeling about editing and
studying and reverse engineering
greatness my walk my wife walks in her
I'm like what are you doing this this is
a little strange like you're caught
doing something
weird and then I do the walk for her and
she goes that's really cute you should
do that and getting that stample of
approv my wife's like okay I might try
this on stage next time but uh I want to
bring this right back to you which is
this how would you describe your
communication
style what makes you unique and
different Sean I'm just curious about
your self-awareness and how you perceive
the way you come across to people I
don't know I would actually be
interested in your response um and I
don't know how strong my self- awareness
is but a few things I try to do um I do
try to depreciate be self-depreciating
um that's a powerful communication thing
again A lot of times people's defenses
are up so if you could be vulnerable or
transparent I think vulnerability and
transparent I like to be known for just
real real talk uh perception of course
might not be perceived that way but for
just
being a complete open book on almost any
podcast I'll go they'll go what's off
limits here what can't we go I'm like I
don't know why anything would be off
limits as far as I know my phone's
tapped right now the internet facial
recognition I just uploaded my face to
an AI generator you know on the trend
privacy has got to be gone so why
wouldn't I tell you anything I'm happy
to share all my numbers because I share
them with the government and I trust you
way more than the government like they
know my numbers and so I'd be happy to
tell you mine so just happens to so kind
of a vulnerability raw want to be known
for for truth and and then I think a
huge word for me would be Clarity I
don't want to waste people's time so
when I sit in a communication situation
the way I get fr frustrated and I still
and I would say frustrated because I'm
still learning you can learn from the
wins and the losses the mistakes that
you observe is we've all probably been
there too you're like where's this going
this person lost me then I'm thinking
why' they lose me I'm they're opening up
I'm not sure what we're talking about
how are they framing this what's
happening so my Pursuit is to be clear
and then I think probably the other big
word for me would be teacher so even on
my YouTube video I have some live
streams minute for minute no editing 45
minutes one's on its way to 3 million
views I teach off of a slide deck I just
talk on the webcam USB microphone teach
off a slide deck which by the way is a
good crutch is a helpful crutch I got
notes behind not afraid to look down and
read my notes so that I can read a
pre-written poignant paragraph because I
want to deliver Clarity I'm not Mo most
frustrated or I'm not most worried about
someone seeing oh he looked down and
read his notes I'm most worried about
the information being clear and
effective and so it's it's really coming
from a teacher hat which as far as I
almost anybody may be my competitors or
whatever they'd be teachers as well but
I think I go back to that almost
studying and wanting to have teaching
best practices very Point driven a lot
of stuff I'll teach will at least have
three Five Points so there's
organization to it and you could argue
that it would probably be um in fact on
stage that uh the
preacher from my experience especially
in Ministry comes into um how I would
deliver business content as well and
some of the attributes of preachers that
I love the most is again if it's clear
if it's engaging if there is humor to
reset attention my years in youth
ministry I think is helpful fast forward
now to kind of tick tock and I don't
think it's an age thing I think that
adults appreciate it as well but it's
especially if you want to connect to the
next generation one of the things you
learn is you can't drone on and be
monotonous for very long without losing
their intention so it might be the
consistent insert the insertion of of a
joke of a pop culture reference of
something all of those little details
have found their way into my
communication style over the years but I
I don't know if we have time I'm curious
from your observational standpoint I'm
might not be able to see the forest from
the trees if there's anything you think
is distinct about my communication style
I think your spot on I would use
different words and I I I wrote down my
words so I'll share them with you so
that there's a reflection here for you I
I would probably put you right like one
of the top attributes that come to my
mind is high energy I if I don't know
and I don't know I would guess you're an
extrovert I remember walking by the
auditorium when you were speaking at uh
grow with video I was like oh my God
that's like coffee for your brain it's
like woo Sean is just on it right now
he's cranked it from four to like 12 and
he's high energy you are very clear
intentional deliberate speaker you're
very
persuasive I believe there's that same
teacher DNA whether it comes from uh
youth ministry or whatever there is the
the preacher vibe in you not to say that
you're preachy but people who know how
to command the word and a phrase and and
control the energy and the room and
moderate their own energy you definitely
have that I'd also add the word stoic in
there that and and you're very
persistent like when you want to say
something you're going to say it and
you're not super uh concerned whether or
not somebody's going to like wow why is
he saying that you know what you want to
do and you're there to deliver deliver
whatever it is your intention is and
it's okay that some people misread that
and that's I think that's a good thing
you're you're not so caught up in
yourself that you're second guessing
what it is that you're saying I would
consider your sense of humor
like there's some dad jokes thrown in
there and I like it and people like that
some puns and pop culture references I
saw you sprinkle them in you don't do it
too heavy because you're not trying to
like be a comedian on stage but you do
that because it brings some levity and
it makes you way more relatable so those
were my words I appreciate that you know
and the funny thing about humor I was
listening to a talk about this Rec
that's a tough one I don't know if I'm
good at it because the problem is
depending on the room depends on how
good the the humor hits or not not
because is the pop cult reference
understood I think the dad joke is funny
but historically dad jokes your wife
doesn't think it's funny and when your
kids are old enough they don't think
it's funny either it's like the dad joke
is for the dad and it's terrible and so
um that has actually been a a pitfall
I've fallen into and I appreciate you
giving me some feedback and it was all
kind and so I'm always open to critical
feedback in fact it's my preference
because that's how you get better iron
sharpens iron I like that pain um but
humor is a tough one and that's one I'd
want to prove on because I was listening
to a talk that's saying to your point
Kevin Hart any comedian they test in
small clubs lots of jokes to narrow down
one oftentimes one set for an entire
year that can impact a larger group of
people you're in trouble if some people
get it and only a portion of the
audience gets it but probably one of the
biggest mistakes you can make as a
communicator is also alienating another
P part of your audience a so how do you
maybe at times do that a few times but
not too much so that you don't push
anybody away and you at least include as
many people as possible reaching people
where they are John Maxwell wrote a book
called everybody communicates but not
everybody connects what is our goal here
he's said the number one question for
any Communicator is first none of the
stuff we just talked about it's who are
you talking to your degree of
understanding we say the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins so on
yoube the Creator who understands the
viewer best wins when you have empathy
and understanding and Clarity of the
problems and Ambitions of the viewer you
want to reach on the other side that
goes everything because who what we
could argue this person's funny or this
person's not funny this person's a good
communicator this person's not it's
actually kind of subjective it it it's
the combination of them plus the
audience in fact there's not everybody
thinks Kevin Hart's funny or as a Kevin
Hart fan you're not everybody's cup of
tea I'm not everybody's cup of tea uh
you aren't not everybody body loves the
future like it's fine like so actually
it's kind of like finding your community
finding your voice and also finding your
people finding the way you communicate
being yourself having that authenticity
and and improving and uh and then
leaving being okay with the people who
don't resonate with you but going deep
with the people who do and having as
much empathy and understanding for your
audience I'll briefly share a story I
speak at Social Media Marketing world
every year uh mostly over the last few
years my friend Michael stellner and um
two years back this might have been pre
pre- pandemic so there was a couple
years where it didn't happen so this
might have been 2019 I got my reports
but they do a great job of surveying the
audience and I bombed terribly bombed
Phil Maran reaches out to me he's like
hey we've known you to be really a love
speaker here but you did you got one of
the lowest scores out of all of the
speakers and they have like a 100
speakers so I was like this oh my gosh
it was it was Heavy I was like shoot
what happened what had happened was I
complet completely misunderstood the
audience what they wanted was no fluff
tactics uh Etc but what I did was I just
I I was on the community floor so I I
thought oh it was a newbie beginner so I
thought it'd be more story driven um and
it was it was very beginner it was Heavy
story and it absolutely disconnected
tactical social media managers that were
there wanted didn't want to any of that
it was kind of a waste of their time and
they didn't think I was funny maybe also
because of the value I wasn't delivering
I really learned about a knowing who
your audience is also learned to take
full ownership like my fault I could
have done a better job to uh make sure I
I knew who I was talking to Etc and then
I wanted to get better after the and and
the mistake was that exact talk because
I just did a talk I had just done
previously crushed two weeks earlier at
a different event what was the
difference who is in the audience and
the understanding of delivering it to
that audience Mike said hey you want to
come back can you do better than last
time I said Mike I really think I can
I know who I'm talking to now I know
that you just want no FL I don't need to
tell a story let me open up my deck let
me share some screenshots of analytics I
can go as tactical as you want bro let's
go deep um but taking full
responsibility for my mistake and
learning from it man knowing who you're
talking to their education level are you
as a beginner intermediate Advanced uh
what's their background whether it's
maybe some humor some stories spoke in
Florida earlier this year um to a lot
more Gen X and Baby Boomers and inserted
last minute a story about my grandfather
who served in the Army aircore and my
grandmother who they met she was in the
Air Corp as well as a mechanic on planes
and I shared the story had people coming
after me that was the story that
resonated because I thought this room
will relate with that and family and
Legacy these were insurance providers
and financial man I was like this story
matters here I don't know if this story
would matter as much if I'm speaking to
a gen Z audience those Details Matter
really understanding who is it you're
talking to that could be the key to
power up your communication
did you get a chance to go back and do
that talk yet I did so I've been I think
I was back at least maybe this last year
was the first year back since the um
pandemic I did a new talk I talked about
the perfect video recipe which is one of
the chapters in YouTube secret second
edition and um and it crushed good
scores great scores and by the way and a
probably probably one of the talks that
I most overprepared for because of the
overcorrection of literally the worst
scores of my life like being the last
place I'm the worst speaker at this
entire event it's Su man and especially
uh I mean you got to be able to suck it
up but you know learn from your failures
but uh but it it hit me hard because I I
I want to at the things I'm committed to
I want to do my best and it always is a
bummer to disappoint people or to to
strike out but hey we're all going to
strike out sometimes you get up learn
from it failures are the Stepping Stones
to success if you enjoyed this podcast
and are ready for some deep dive YouTube
strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get get access to my
1hour on demand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com